chi chuan sono tornato chiama the fat
mascella crew per tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fatti jr da
una vita che non facevo subito su gta e
ci voleva nichi per portarmi tct a fare
un po di bordello oggi vediamo che
succede perché adesso disco perché siamo
online
come la porta di una ma bene bene bene
non sanno guidare che si sia anche una
stazione di polizia di prima come si
cambia mai a posso fare un'altra partita
contro quanti soldi hai dobbiamo della
national e maghetti ora conteso è che
tra l'altro non produrre la gara a pugni
sul naso ma nei pub la gang non si in
fama e miguel porco o tutto questo
sangue data d'uscita poi dalle cuffie
perché c'era una d'alcune località
volevi hai a porca vacca 6 si mette il
successo e c6 giocare a questo gioco tra
queste fifa non so quale se in quella
posizione con la stessa e di chi ci sono
le moto che ma che nella realtà un
camion y diventi un carlino mi chiedo ma
c'è ancora questo ma è rotto il cazzo
buongiorno
guarda che c hai sopra nel mondo guarda
su destra da techniques for apple
versamenti the radio ma diventato un
gioco fantasy questo oppure vai da moon
e scene di metile alla modalità jet
borchiate verrà dato al totoministri
ammazzarle rubargli labbro
ma dopo presentata in testa però le
imprese
ecco com'è accaduto della morte
nella mia vita non ho presa aia volevo
la moto in volata di munizioni è il tipo
che si no dai c'erano le dissero
aspettano sono troppo presto obiettivo
del video raga sarà che rubare la moto
voler formulare una valutazione lasciato
al quale moto ma vado molto la prendo
subito ma secondo me non riesco a
guidare come mentana fa guidarli non
puoi accedere a questo titolo personale
allora io non lascio la guerra scarpa di
univa una pisciata guerra l'ascia da
guerra ma perché buongiorno chissà se
l'affetto ma porca [ __ ] che mal era in
testa che poi perde sangue dall'addome
giusto anche a lanciarla porco [ __ ] a
iaia la pula jajaja news uno di tipo la
gara senza morto non metto a posto tutto
c'è anche la porta è partito a terra
spiega la donna è una ma adesso perché
vettoretto è un pò morto per scomparso
quando provi a carboni mickey box mani
di bossi dice no come i posti fa fuori
prima
lo scambiamo la seconda canzoneri anno
esatto non ci azzecca una sega con
quello che sta succedendo la canzone
solo su happy all'iniqua di qua che cosa
strani che ho visto da quando non esiste
più la parte davanti della macchina e
prova ancora a posto
scusami scusami non volevo che stavo
scherzando si chiama è l'ultimo
all'animazione ho visto che adesso non
si fermano vicine ma è ritornato insomma
avviene con noi che questo sono stato
bravo a fare questa cosa e hogan e basta
ma questa e non ora ma è ancora morto
lui adesso possiamo adesso forse sopra
chopper sopra fissi il modulo nati
salver signora scalera riuscita per
rispondere al telefono e si è trovata
una macchina che madonna che salto
indiano shuttle sport cav una nota va
veloce sta cosa in italia di 5.000
dollari perché mai preso però ucciso per
bene va bene l'importante argomento sono
preso tra la borsa super è stato
bellissimo ha visto davanti alla polizia
così anche di buongiorno
salve belli facciamo attenzione però se
non fanno ha detto nier rispetti il
semaforo è tutto a posto in america
quindi non hanno detto niente non hanno
fatto nulla ancora si chiama addetti
basta questi giochi per adulti io non
sono capace
basta giochiamo ai giochi di merda
giorno buon appetito bene oggi ma leggo
la mia miley per contro antonio con
l'inferno salute antonio
ciao sotto dei pass però come ragazze
sotto questo camion bello perdonare lo
vede lo vedessi riguarda le a piedi si
va lontano come ha fatto ma io lo
capisco la gente come fa spararti da 20
kg come guarda la mini mappa molto brava
buonasera tutto day di oggi sono passati
mandiamo all'iter colandonio buongiorno
antonio non devi neanche sparare anche
evidente andata via ti stava aspettando
adesso teneramente lanciato una granata
in pagina
cos'è una sfida che non vincerò mai
esploso che curiosi e successo e sposò
malissimo sono esplosi tutti vinco io
grazie di sole bravo questo gioco è ben
altro matos secondo me si è fatto male
ma me ne sono sicuro vitale appena
tagliate cagliate pende focara perché ci
sente
ma il pari è kurt and her nanes debutto
cabron alla riuscito il marcos de
narcotrafficante so il narcotrafficante
elka bravo
morto [ __ ] di tornare nelle case di
porta una ricetta ma perché l'ambulanza
mi deve uccidere che sia un ambulanza
eccolo eccolo lo ha doppiato attenzione
come si chiama mila milhouse mila un
giorno che [ __ ] e la macchina bros e
riesce a rubare symphony di test più che
altro visto che mi ammazza ero proprio
nel iv dire chissà come mi ammazzo siamo
che se l'è presa la signorina
quindi ragazzi questa l'episodio non gta
su nikic con i sunniti soprani di bones
sul suo canale trovate anche l'altro
episodio che abbiamo fatto sempre
insieme cosa mi piace ringrazio nichi
per aver partecipato questo video sarda
che si chiede e ci vediamo al prossimo
video dai ragazzi
[Musica]
laddove come più fastidi